joining us now with reaction Republican
congressman Ron de santis saw
Weissenberg deputy independent counsel
in the whitewater investigation of Bill
Clinton and attorney Scott Bolden
gentlemen it's great to see all of you
so let's start with you you're an expert
in indictments you've unpacked a lot of
them in your career tell us about this
one and your reaction to the 13 Russians
named well it's a very narrow indictment
it's what the main count is what we call
a Klein conspiracy under the general
conspiracy statute and it basically says
that the Russians involved here
conspired to defraud federal
governmental functions there are three
chief examples one they lied on their
visa applications two they lied to the
Federal Election Commission by
withholding the fact that they were
getting foreign money and and third has
to do with the foreign agent
Registration Act they should have
registered as foreign agents and they
didn't and one thing that I don't think
anybody has picked up on I don't know
how significant it is legally it's not
that significant the indictment doesn't
even allege that these Russians were
part of the Russian government just says
that they were Russian organizations but
Laura it's very narrow it's a very
narrow charge and this is what
congressman heck
Danny heck said earlier today about
whether Donald Trump is truly vindicated
by this narrow indictment let's watch
defendants knowingly and intentionally
conspired with each other and here's the
relevant language and with persons known
and unknown to the grand jury to defraud
the United States etc etc this
indictment of these 13 individuals is
not the end of it just like the
indictments of Mr Man afford
mr. gates mr. Flinn and mr. Papadopoulos
weren't the end of it at all to be
continued
congressman De Santis the president
seemed to feel like he was vindicated in
his tweet today but is that a little
premature well Laura I mean remember
this whole thing started with
allegations played up by the media and
my Democratic colleagues that there was
a criminal conspiracy
see between Trump's campaign and the
Russian government to subvert the
election this indictment doesn't even
come close to doing that and in fact for
rod Rosen Stein to say no Americans were
involved and it had no effect on the
election it just shows you that they
have been promising and promoting this
narrative for over a year now really a
year and a half and at this stage I
don't see why you need a special counsel
for any of these indictments they are
all run-of-the-mill cases that could be
handled by the Justice that known and
unknown
they also said people known and unknown
did conspire with the Russians couldn't
that then and I've been a lawyer for
awhile so Saul you can Saul and Scott
can contradict me but doesn't that leave
the door open for future naming a future
individual but you'd have to ask
yourself Laura on this virtually all
indictments virtually all indictments
conspiracy indictments have that
language but rod Rosenstein did not say
that there was that there was no
collusion with the Trump campaign he
says this indictment doesn't allege that
there was collusion indictment doesn't
allege that the the election was
affected or so you can't say anything
broader than that
I certainly have to agree with my
colleague you know I don't really know
what the Republicans are celebrating
this is one bucket this is one
indictment of cyber space they're still
this investigation continues well every
chance you get you want to say that
there's no clock I think indicates the
president does a pulse I agree with it
it's it's a it's a narrow it's a it's a
narrow indictment but I think it is very
key that the Russian involvement in this
election was both pro-trump anti-trump
to help their work at first Jill helping
Jill Stein at one point I mean they seem
to have their their hands all over
everything they I would too if I were
the Russians and I was sowing discord
and supported Trump over at happy I
would certainly do both so that happy
were promoting that have 400 Russian as
well that have Pro and anti Trump
rallies on the same
I mean Ron you can once I'm in on this
to me that seems like a stretch I mean I
think Saul is right this is this is one
indictment the idea that Muller is gonna
kind of close up shop tomorrow we just
got ten million dollars in that
ridiculous Republican budget that was
just signed another ten million bucks
into the lot special councils office I
know why these ten million dollars is
gonna wrap it up but Ron I mean so we
have all this time that's happened it's
elapsed congressional committees special
Council and what evidence is there of
collusion other than the steal dossier
which has been discredited and so I
think it's one thing to say that there
were Russian nationals or even Russian
government involved although I would be
note none of the hacking which I thought
was the most serious none of that was
alleged in the indictment and and that
was not something that that's dealt with
so that's what you have and I just think
that so much of this has been based off
wishful thinking by the press and the
Democrats and the steel dossier rather
than hard facts what about all right
what about the Republicans who are
leading all of these investigations and
certainly believe that there was Russian
meddling let me tell you something I'm a
former prosecutor right prosecution's
don't start at the top and go down they
start at the bottom it's called a
pyramid prosecution and you start at the
bottom until you get to the top and you
cut the top off you cut the head of it
and there's a difference off there's a
difference between there's just one
bucket of cyber bullying
there was other collusion and other
facts that are still being investigated
so Russian meddling is different than a
criminal conspiracy between Trump and
the Russian government that's a huge
leap and there's nothing evidence to
make that leap but they haven't they
haven't offered I think anything on that
front and Rosenstein essentially said
that that that's not what they're
talking about in this indictment that's
all I want it I want to go go go into
this more with you because when you see
that amount of time they have had
they've interviewed a lot of people
they've had reviewed a lot of documents
it is quite something I think at this
juncture in the investigation to come up
with okay
they they were trying to manipulate the
election like who didn't think that the
Russians were trying to manipulate and
get involved in the election but before
Trump was even announced as a candidate
they were meddling and what did the
Obama administration do exactly to stop
it they were helping last time I checked
they were approving sales of to almost
20% of our uranium supply to a Russian a
Russian company bought through a
Canadian company I mean you talk and
start talking about the ways we helped
Russia we helped rush a lot during the
Obama administration that's that's true
that's a that's that's true it's more of
a political and historical point and as
you point out the indictment says it
started in 2014 well before Trump
announced but listen there's no question
what scott says is right it's a it's a
piece it's a piece of the puzzle but
what the congressman said is is correct
too I mean it is it is a good day for
president Trump it is significant that
the investigation has gone on this long
and you don't have the collusion case
and keep in mind is Andrew McCarthy has
pointed out if you look at the Flynn
plea papers and you look at the
Papadopoulos plea papers but
particularly Flynn's it looks like there
is going to be no collusion case
certainly no collusion that Flynn would
have known about so all signs do point
to the fact that there will not be a
major and when I say what what what are
they looking for they're looking for
obstruction of justice interfering with
the investigation there's no record
there is no obstruction case period mm
well we got the president's own words
I'm not gonna go down that rabbit hole
with you I think there's a lot of
evidence there but you wouldn't have a
rabbit hole it's the law in the rabbit
hole right right now I mean the the the
Democrats have turned up the heat on the
Republican committees looking into this
because they're they're arguing that oh
you guys are just interfering with what
these special counsel is trying to
get out so these indictments come out
today and what's next for the house
investigations oh the house
investigation is going to continue the
State Department is next kind of under
the microscope and then you are going to
be we are in the house gonna scrutinize
people like Jim clapper and John Brennan
and see their role in this but I can
tell you Laura six months ago people
didn't know that the Democrats paid for
the dossier what's happened since then
you've had a lot of very senior people
in both the DOJ and FBI either get
demoted or leave the government they
wouldn't have done that if they had done
everything by the book and I've got to
say John Brennan speaking of Brennan all
of you will love this tweet he sent out
a tweet today after the indictment came
out he said DOJ statement indictments
revealed the extent motivations of
Russian interference in 2016 election
claims of a hoax in tatters my take
implausible that Russian actions did not
influence the views and votes of at
least some Americans okay I guess but
how does that justify a special council
being called on this president but when
Rosenstein Stein picked the special
counsel said we got to do the special
counsel that was based on what's all I
go back to two rods decision to call the
Special Counsel which I think was absurd
on its face you can close it out I
disagree I think it absolutely is called
for by the regulation just like the
President Obama the special counsel but
he had him from the point is you don't
you can't have the administration that
has been that has been accused of
throwing an election investigating
itself if you look you don't know you
don't have to have you don't have to
have probable cause under this part of
the regulation and look and look I think
that Loretta Lynch should have appointed
a special counsel but because of the
Hillary Clinton email thing you don't
have to but the point is the language of
the special counsel regulation allows
you to do it so you can do a lot you
should Ron you're taking them Scott so
rod Rosen Stein and the appointing order
did not
identify the crime to be investigated he
said investigate commis
counterintelligence investigation the
regulations only allow for a special
counsel for a criminal investigation he
did not do that and that's why a lot of
us have been concerned that this
investigation doesn't have any real
limits against Russian meddling in the
election and whatever else that pathway
that happened before Trump ever
announced it is exactly you had to have
a special process all right guys thank
you so much have a great weekend